[موسيقى]
الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله نظم الاف من المستوطنين وجماعات
متطرفه ما تعرف بمسيره الاعلام في القدس
المحتله وافادت مراسله الجزيره بان
المسيره شهدت اعتداءات بالحجاره على
فلسطينيين وطواقم صحفيه قرب باب العامود
في القدس
فقد انضم اليهم ثلاثه وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بينهم وزير الامن القومي تمر
بن جفير وعدد من اعضاء الكنيست
[موسيقى]
وقال النائب المتحدث باسم الامين العامه
للامم المتحده ردا على سؤال عما تعرف
بمسيره الاعلام الاسرائيليه قال ان منسق
الامم المتحده الخاص بعمليه هي السلام حتى
جميع الاطراف على ضبط النفس وتجنب
الاستفزازات والحفاظ على الهدوء
من جهتها نددت الخارجيه الامريكيه
بالهتافات العنصريه التي اطلقت خلال مسيره
الاعلام واقل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه من الولايات المتحده تعارض بشكل
لا لبس فيه اللغه العنصريه بكل اشكالها
اصدر الرئيس الاوكراني قرارا باعاده تشكيل
مجلس استشاري يهدف لانهاء ما وصفه باحتلال
واعاده دمج شبه جزيره القرد والغاء الحكم
الذاتي
وقد اعلنت السلطات شبه جزيره القرن
المواليه لروسيا استكمال اعمال الصيانه في
سكه الحديد المتضرره بين
هذا وحمل رئيس برلماني شبه جزيره القرم
الاوكرانيه مسؤوليه الحادث
قالت الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان الخط
المستهدفه كان يستخدم لنقل الجنود الروس
والذخيره والعتاد لمواصله ما وصفته
بالعدوان على البلاد
نقلت صحيفه عن مسؤول اوكراني وصفته
بالرفيع استعداد اربع دول اوروبيه لتزويد
كيف بطائرات اف 16 كما نقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤول امريكي ان اداره الرئيس بايدن
متردده في ارسال طائرات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا
تعقد دول مجموعه السبعه قمه في اليابان
لمناقشه عدد من القضايا الدوليه وذلك على
هامش القمه قالت الرئاسه الفرنسيه ان قاده
مجموعه سبع متفقون على تاكيد موقفهم بشان
دعوه الصين لممارسه نفوذها لدى روسيا
لدفعها لوقف حربها على اوكرانيا واكد
مستشار للرئيس الفرنسي في حديثه للصحافيين
فيرسوما في هيروشيما عفوا ان هذه القمه لن
تكون قمه مواجهه مع الصين بل قمه للتفاهم
وتوضيح الشروط
قال الرئيس الصيني
مستعده لمساعده بلدان اسيا الوسطى على
تحسين انفاذ القانون والامن وبناء القدرات
الدفاعيه واضاف الرئيس الصيني خلال قمه
زعماء دول اسيا الوسطى والذي يعقد للمره
الاولى منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
اضافنا دول اسيا الوسطى لديها الركائز
والقدرات لتصبح مركزا مهما لربط اسيا مع
القاره الاوروبيه
في السودان رصد مراسله الجزيره في الخرطوم
مع اشتباكات بين الجيش والقوات الدعم
السريع كما افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره بان
ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا نتيجه للمعارك بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
انتهى الموجز لما كنت طبت اوقاتكم بكل خير